[Music]
question for the married men in this
room
did you guys sign a prenup nope
nope yup what is that again you did i
did oh
what's a prenup dude how does that
process in the conversation go
listen [ __ ] you're gonna sign this
prenup oh just like that no we just we
talked about it because like um
you know because i mean at the end of
the day marriage released like a
contract right and we were just kind of
like yeah you know it makes sense that
financially let's discuss what happens
if
we break up if it doesn't work out so
what did you guys have discussed
especially since uh she's coming from
canada
right so it was like certain aspects of
like okay
she would get living wages at some point
for
you know if we broke up because you know
i brought her out here and then like
for a long time she you get to pay her
in canadian
that's cheaper i pay her in ketchup
chips yes
nice no but it's like you know you
disrupted her income ability for a bit
yeah yeah i get it yeah so um and didn't
she run
or own a beauty salon she had one but
she closed it down when she came out to
move out here
and then also since i am a youtuber and
i
use her face in a lot of my videos and
vlogs
there was that as a part of it it's like
okay she is a big part of
my youtube revenue so there's like a
little percentage of that as well it's a
bunch of [ __ ]
figure out the percentage well it was it
was annoying because you know my lawyer
had her you know she's supposed to get
her own lawyer too so it's you know
did she yeah yeah well here's the thing
my lawyer recommended
lawyers for her right but still oh they
were making they recommended a [ __ ]
beast for her
her lawyer was [ __ ] savage she was
like no we should we should
go hard on this and they went hard but
eventually like but you know we we came
to
an agreement and we're like yeah this
this makes sense cool it sounds like
you're going through a divorce without
before you even get married i mean kind
of this is a preparation
yeah and they're mature man it's almost
like expecting to fail but not really
just being double sure right it's like
buying insurance
it's actually very responsible well
here's here's the thing right because uh
i mean one of the reasons why like i
feel like i love chia is because she's
such a
level-headed person like she's able to
look at things very objectively and she
was like yeah cool i mean yeah it makes
sense for us to do something like this
who brought it up um i feel like it just
kind of came up
like somebody had a spearhead in the
conversation no no no it was mutually
brought up on
to both parties tim brought it up when
you're talking about
his lawyer brought it up
hey so it's not me my lawyer is telling
me i have to get a thing
just kind of something that comes up in
conversation you know did you light
candles first
um pretty romantic [ __ ] nuptial dinner
yeah yeah i serenaded her all the all my
uh
demands and then uh when you got her to
sign did you like toast
like it was kind of like well it was
more like a relief like that where
got that conversation over this and
let's you know be done with it and let's
move on yeah that's cool
then how short like what was the time
timeline
like how much later did you guys
actually get legally married
um i think maybe like um almost like a
couple months later
because it was it was just kind of
another checklist of things we got to
get done before we get married yeah was
it engagement and then
you know it was engagement cleanup talk
we were engaged for about a year as soon
as we got engaged
she went into like wedding planning mode
basically you know i'm saying booking
venues and all that [ __ ] and then
prenup talk came up and then um i talked
to
just who i needed to talk to and we
figured it out
that's cool it's very responsible yeah
well this story here is about
the doctor dre and his
wife which is now apparently going to be
an ex-wife because she filed for divorce
after 24 years of marriage
billion dollars four years he is worth
one billion dollars oh yeah yeah
so he is a billionaire 100 yes
that's the dream yeah so
here's the thing initially it was
reported like
they're going to get divorced because
she served them with a divorce
right and then that's when dr jay was
like oh
it's cool we're good cause we signed a
prenup and
but then that's when um
trust renegotiate that [ __ ]
nicole which is his wife that's when
nicole's like
oh we did but do you remember
how you kind of like you kind of forced
me to sign this and it was very very
very
like right before very short time right
before our wedding
which apparently is very important it's
an important detail when it comes
to now getting divorced the fact that
they signed this prenup really close to
the wedding date
apparently that is a factor and then
also she was saying that she just felt
cornered and very like pressured and
intimidated
by andre and that she felt like she had
no option but to hire a lawyer and it
was
through his lawyer so that's how she was
able to obtain a lawyer
and that she unwillingly signed the
agreement
but then after like two years after they
got married dr dre was the one that
apparently he felt that he acknowledged
that
he felt ashamed and that he that he had
pressured her to sign this
and so he grabbed copies of the
agreement according to her
and ripped them up so she said we both
understood that there was no
prenup and it was null and void
so why are you bringing it up now
because it's not supposed to be a thing
that we even have to worry about
okay so now it's like a battle and to
see like
what's gonna go down are they in
california because i heard that
um california even with prenups
they don't really go by it yeah exactly
right you get a certain percentage no
matter the [ __ ] one almost yeah
like no matter whatever you wrote you
know and then sometimes prenups marriage
doesn't even matter if you're
uh what do you call it domestically
cohabiting oh
like if you're just together for over
seven years
yeah something like that you're like
legally married is different yeah but i
think for here it's
common law common law yeah you've been
together for that long already then
they're entitled to uh whatever i know
that because i used to bust my buddies
balls about it because he waited like 10
years to get engaged even
and i just go calm and lost you might as
well
[ __ ] it roll the dice get your little
tax break
yeah damn i'm confused about the her
stance on like
saying that it's nolan and void because
it's like pretty much what she's saying
is i'm gonna sue you for more
uh like i'm getting half [ __ ]
like whatever this is it's like it
doesn't matter because i deserve more
exactly right she's like i was there
while you built beats by dre
[ __ ] i'm getting my i tested all the
headphones i need to get paid
i think like if she could be like you
know how many times you complained to me
and i had to listen to that [ __ ]
that is a [ __ ] consultation service
boom three dimes she earns every dime
right yeah that's the work that like the
significant other has to go through
whether man or
woman right like it's like if she yep
yeah here they are
untold monetary value there is there is
yeah she's probably like you know what
the [ __ ] happened at work today she goes
really that's what happened she's like
[ __ ] she's like [ __ ] sake
to be a wife and
so is he dropping all the way down from
like the hip-hop baller ratings back
down to like half now i don't know we'll
see how
depends on how much she's entitled to
they're pretty much like the you know
like in a boxing ring with a
ding-ding-ding and
that's kind of what's happening here
also am i tripping or the city of hope
logo it looks like titties
they're the belly buttons yeah it's a
belly button and a little cucumber was
like
i don't know why is it like cancer i
know i know
there's titty cancer there's belly
button tattoos like
on some like psychiatrist [ __ ] i looked
and i was like why is it titties there's
like oh
that's the city of old logos what i
totally see a baby i see it yeah maybe
that sexual innuendo was on purpose to
like
get people to remember it's the guru
it's a groom us
to be titillated by cancer research
that [ __ ] blows my mind after 24 years
all of a sudden you just erupt
i mean things like that probably not all
of a sudden it probably has been like
a long time coming for them we don't
know what's going on
but it it happens though it's
interesting how like things like that
sometimes it happens to couples that you
least expect where you know
just like oh they're so in love and
whatever and then before you know it
they're like
what they can't get different well do we
know if they're getting their divorce
because of deep-seated things or is she
just on her period
[Laughter]
yeah maybe she's just tell me to come
across the table and slap you
is that what you're trying to do you
know nikki's not here i just like what
joe was saying where he's like 24 years
and then out of the blue
[Laughter]
it's like yeah maybe she's just on her
period this is a bad mood man why don't
you just wait a couple of weeks
yeah right just to test it i'm in a room
full of it why did you just take some
tylenol or something and then see how
she feels yeah that's stupid
but yeah so then it was a it's a very
important
like factor the fact that she said like
two years after then that's when you
decided to rip it up or whatever
and they're saying is because most
likely during that time not a lot of his
money was being made so then
like the 22 years after is where the
good amount of wealth
was made obviously she's the one who's
filing right
she is the one who's filing and she's
also an attorney by the way
who [ __ ] shakes you gotta watch out i
was just about to say is that an
argument to be made where it's like okay
we signed this before you got money now
you got money we gotta throw the whole
contract away make a new one like is
that fair
you know what i'm worried about is i'm
such a deals hound and addict
that if my wife was a lawyer and she's
like i'll write the prenup i'd be like
she's like you can save a lot of money
doing that i'm like that's a good idea
[Laughter]
that's a good deal she said that's good
yeah i gotta pre-nup what my wife wrote
in she's a lawyer yeah
i got to pay [ __ ] is that so i got a
hookup do i build my own bachelor party
be like i saved so much on lawyer fees
it's on me boys
everyone's there drinking my white bread
that poor poor fool exactly
damn man how could we didn't sign a
prenup i don't know you want to no
because we
well now it's like a postman well you
can sign up there's actually posting ups
are real
it's after you get married and then you
it's you know the same [ __ ] just after
you get married
not that i want to i know yeah no but
did you want it you wanted to
no i just brought it up and like as a
sign of respect kind of like
hey just so you know we could do this if
you feel more comfortable and you were
like nah and i'm like
all right then i don't need it either so
we're good oh yeah that's it you you
brought it up and i brought it up yeah
do you do you is it because you felt
like he brought more to the table
so you're like um uh i didn't even
consider that
really it was just more like like i just
didn't want
any sort of like weird things coming up
later so i'm like hey we're good
cause geo brought that up because i
brought more to the table because both
of my parents
are they're divorced and they both own
houses
so for her when we first had this
conversation she was like you know if
20 years down the line if we get
divorced the three like we own a house
you also own two other houses that are
going to get passed down all those
houses are mine
like so she's like if you want to sign
one i
would understand because you bring way
more to the table than i do she's a bad
lawyer i'd end up considering something
yeah because of casey's family they do
own businesses so i probably did
consider something like that that's what
i was thinking maybe you're thinking
like oh you brought more to the table
yeah i'm thinking that casey's like we
don't need a prenup i ain't got no money
in my bank account i don't give a [ __ ]
like what are you gonna take
you can take [ __ ] because it's like you
guys were asking when you rented a place
you didn't even have home yet
i feel like that is part of the
conversation that we had yeah
we did talk about that oh i see because
jill's family is way different they have
one house that needs to be split with
four kids mine is two houses with one
kid
i have zero houses dude casey your life
is sick bro
casey's like i don't know is my credit
good like and then and then his mom's
like yeah i've been thinking
and then he's like i don't know do i
have any assets and his mom's like yeah
you'll be fine
that is sick your parents are
responsible dude that's smart
they are really responsible i gotta
[ __ ] try to get my mom a condo
really you know what's crazy is my my
mom called me like a couple months ago
like during the pandemic and then she
was like
she was like you know what i think it's
one about time we we need to sit down
and also talk about like
a will a will and all that stuff i was
like oh [ __ ] and then they're like
talking about yeah we gotta figure out
how we're gonna disperse the money
and all these things that makes sense my
parents just have hoarder assets
probably got cool collectibles from the
60s steve gets to steve
three tons of junk i'm like thank you
very much steve gets 500 copies of
people magazine
jen gets all the dead cats in the house
no matter what wall-to-wall including
the backyard and i'm like okay
that makes sense
[Music]